[موسيقى]
نرحب بمشاهدي فرونسباكات ومستمعي مونتي
كارلو الدوليه كما نرحب بضيوف البرنامج
الذين تشاهدونهم على الشاشه ويمكنكم ان
تتفاعلوا ما ما يقولون على صفحتنا على
فيسبوك وعلى صفحه البرنامج على تويتر قمه
اوروبيه اوكرانيه في كييف غدا رئيسه
المفوضيه الاوروبيه
يرسلت الى العاصمه الاوكرانيه رفقه رئيس
المجلس الاوروبي شارل ميشيل ومسؤولين
اخرين للقاء الرئيس فولوديمير زينين لهذه
القمه الهدف المعلن هو الاعراب عن وقوف
الاتحاد الاوروبي الى جانب اوكرانيا ولكن
هل هذا سيترجم
بانضماما سريع لكابر الاتحاد الاوروبي الى
اي حد السلطات الاوكرانيه ستطبق الاصلاحات
المطلوبه بما في ذلك مكافحه الفساد او
اصلاح المحكمه الدستوريه او طريقه تعيين
القضاه الدول الاوروبيه تتضوء الاخضر
لامداد اوكرانيا باسلحه ثقيله فهل هذه
القمه هي رساله اضافيه الى موسكو نناقش
الموضوع ومعي من
وهو الناطق الرسمي للاتحاد الاوروبي
لمنطقه الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا من
كياف فولوديمير شوماكوف وهو دبلوماسي
اوكراني سابق ومعنا من برلين عامر الموسوي
وصحفي ومحلل سياسي اهلا وسهلا بكم قبل ان
نبدا نستمع لمقالته
اتفقت هيئه المفوضين والحكومه الاوكرانيه
بشكل اساسي على طريقه العمل نفسها
فقط على دعم الشعب الاوكراني ولكن ايضا
على كيفيه بناء مستقبل اوكرانيا في
الاتحاد الاوروبي
وماذا قال جوزيف بوريل
يسعدني ان اعلن لرئيس الوزراء الاوكراني
ان بعثه المساعده العسكريه للاتحاد
الاوروبي ستدرب 15 الف جنديا اوكرانيا
اضافي
والتحذير الى الاوروبيين والى الغرب جاء
على لسان الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
هو امر لا يصدق ولكن هي الحقيقه نحن
مهددون مجددا من قبل دبابات الالمانيه
التي تحمل رمز الصليب على متنها مجددا
تستعد الدول الغربيه لمحاربه روسيا على
اراضي اوكرانيا بمساعده اذرع مؤيده لهتلر
وبايادي مقاتل بانديرا
من بيروت اوروبا قدمت الكثير الى اوكرانيا
هل يمكنها ان تعطي المزيد وما الذي يمكن
ان تفعل اكثر مما فعلت حتى الان
اولا شكرا جزيلا استاذ طارق الاستضافه
للتحيات لكم المشاهدين طبعا
الاجتماع اليوم يعني دليل افضل دليل
للتضامن الاوروبي باتجاه اوكرانيا وشعب
الاوكراني
يعني تمور علينا ان ننسى بان الروبيه تمر
بمرحله استثنائيه للغايه اول مره نرى بان
هناك دوله تمتلك الاسلحه النوويه في مجلس
الامن في الامم المتحده التي تقوم به
عضوان عسكريه غير مبرر للدوله اخرى وهي
دوله اوروبيه اصلا اوكرانيا فطبعا الاتحاد
الاوروبي لا يمكن ان نكون مكتفيه امام هذا
العضوان وهذا الدعم الاوروبي المسموع من
مستويات حقيقه يعني سواء كان دبلوماسيا
سياسيا عسكريا ماليا ما الى ذلك سيستمر
يعني كما كانت رئيس المفاوض الاوروبيه
اكثر من مره واليوم كذلك يعني الاتحاد
الاوروبي مصمم على مواصله هذه المساعده
هذا الدعم
للشعب للحكومه الاوكرانيه وعلى فكره هناك
ايضا ليس فقط اجماع حول هذا الموضوع
بلاواسم الاوروبيه وانما ايضا في شارع
الاوروبيه هناك تضامن كبير من قبل المواطن
الاوروبي انا شخصيا صرت بعد المدن مثلا في
البرتغال يعني دوله بعيده جدا عن اوكرانيا
وان رايت بعيوني الي مدى التضامن من قبل
المواطن الاوروبي موجود
ونحن سنستمر بذلك
يعني مره اخرى ماليا دبلوماسيا عسكريا
وعلى فكره يعني انا اعتقد انه حتى الكريم
الرئيس الروسي تفاجا بعد ما حدث في اوروبا
يعني كان يفكرون البعض بان الاتحاد
الاوروبي كان نائما بعد ما يعني هذا
التكاتل البروكراتي وما الى ذلك وطبعا
الروبي كان سريع كان ملموس ولا يكون ملموس
والرساله الرسالاتنا للكلام لرسالاتنا
للعالم اننا مستعدون للمزيد طيب
مندمير شوماكوف تبع
ك من بيروت كمتحدث باسم الاتحاد الاوروبي
يعني اوروبا حتى الان وقفت الى جانب
اوكرانيا ولكن الملاحظه ان كل ما تقدم
اوروبا مساعدات كلما تطالب اوكرانيا
بالمزيد
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
وتحيه طيبه من اوكرانيا نعم اوروبا تساعد
بشكل كبير لاوكرانيا وخاصه في مساعده
خيريه وكمان مساعده عسكريه ولكن اكيد
اوكرانيا
تطلب اغضاك على اسلحه متطوره والان
اوكرانيا تطلب الاسلحه هجوميه وهذا منطقي
لان اوكرانيا تحارب مع جيش رقم اثنين في
العالم وبالمناسبه اوكرانيا تحارب بنجاح
وهذا من اجل من الكمال المساعده من ان
اوكرانيا
بان نطلب من بريطانيا وخاصه من امريكا هو
كمان من الدول الغربيه الاسلحه اي اسلحه
لان اوكرانيا نزعت اسلحه نوويه من اجل
السلام فعلنا معاصر ودامت بريطانيا
حمايه حدوته الاوكرانيه وحمايه استقلال
اوكرانيا ولكن للاسف الشديد في سنه 2014
كل هذه الدول الاعمال
واجباتها عندما رؤوسها هجمت على اوكرانيا
في سنه 2014
سرقت من اوكرانيا شبه واحتلت جزء من منطقه
11 شهرا روسيا هجمه الاوكرانيا بشكل شامل
زياده من الاسلحه المتطوره هذا ليست
اوكرانيا اوكرانيا تحتاج هذا الاصل لتردوس
من ارادو على وجود اوكرانيا لم يلحق
وجود اوكرانيا وكمان اوكرانيا الان مفصوله
بدموع والضم نساء واطفال اوكرانيا ان
الروسيه
الاوكرانيه عندها هدف
هدفعه نحن نعيش كل يوم طقس في مدن
ومنها شمال اوكرانيا وكمان منطقه روسيا
دمرت يعني بشكل كبير
في جنوب اوكرانيا نحن نقول دمار التي
روسيا حققت هنا اوكرانيا في اوكرانيا اكثر
من
المانيا النازيين في حرب عالميه الثانيه
طيب عامر الموسوي من برلين تتابع بالتاكيد
الموقف الالماني بالدرجه الاولى الموقف
الاوروبي عموما هناك من طبعا ينخرط في هذا
التوجه وضروره تقديم المزيد من المساعدات
وهناك من يقول يا جماعه
لا يجب ان نستفز روسيا الى هذا الحد ولا
يجب ان نعطي كل الاسلحه التي تطلبها
اوكرانيا وننتظر ربما ولابد ان نراهن على
الورقه الدبلوماسيه تفضل
مساء الخير توفيق عليك وعلى المشاهدين
الكرام وعلى ضيفك من بيروت وكيف طبعا
هنالك انقسام وانا يعني لا اوافق على ما
جاء به السيد ميغيل هنالك انقسام داخل
الشارع الاوروبي حياله مساله تزويد
اوكرانيا بالمزيد من الاسلحه هنالك من
يعني السؤال يتعلق هل تؤدي عمليه
قال هناك دعم اوروبي لاوكرانيا لم يتحدث
عن الاسلحه فقط للتصحيح تفضل يعني نحن
نتحدث عن المزاج الشارع الاوروبي هنالك
انا اتحدث على الاقل في المانيا يعني
المانيا المواطنين الالمان داعمون
لاوكرانيا وداعمون والجميع يعني متعاطف مع
الشعب الاوكراني ولكن هنالك ايضا مخاوف من
ان تؤدي هذه عمليه توريد الاسلحه الى تورط
مباشر للدول الاتحاد الاوروبي والدول
الغربيه في صراع محتدم مع دوله نوويه مثل
روسيا لا ننسى ان حتى ان بوتين لا احد
يتوقع ما الذي يقوم به يعني هو لم يعني لم
يعلن انه سيهجم على اوكرانيا وقال في
البدايه اذا تذكرون قبل سنه انه هي عباره
عن مناورات على الحدود ولكنه ضرب عرض
الحائط القانون الدولي
هنالك رغبه يعني
دعم اوكرانيا واصالها الى الى نقطه تستطيع
ان تفرض اراده سياسيه على على طاوله
المفاوضات نحن نعلم ان الحروب تبدا
بالجبهات ولكنها تنتهي على مفاوضات وعلى
طاوله المفاوضات
بوتين لازال لا لم يصل الى النقطه التي
يستطيع من خلالها ان يجلس على طاوله
المفاوضات هو يرفض المفاوضات
كان بعض مستشاريه يقولون نحن منفتحون على
المفاوضات ولكن بالواقع الحال ليست هنالك
رغبه روسيه لان تجلس على المفاوضات لذلك
انا انتقد يعني الجهود الاوروبيه هنا انها
لا تزال دون مستوى الدعم بالنسبه من
الناحيه العسكريه طبعا هنالك دعم سياسي
وهنالك دعم يعني
بكثير من النواحي الانساني ايضا ولكن
الدعم العسكري لا لم يصل لغايه الان الى
ان يوصل اوكرانيا الى نقطه تستطيع ان تصد
الهجمات الروسيه التي بدات تزداد قوه
ودليل على ذلك ما قاله الرئيس سيلنسكي
قبل يومين او البارحه بان حده الهجومات
بالجبهه في دمباس ودنيس ترتفع اكثر يوم
بعد اخر ذلك
الدول الاوروبيه لغايه حتى ان الولايات
المتحده يعني ليس لديها هنالك الدعم ياتي
بالدرجات ولكن هذه الدرجات لا تسعف
الاوكرانيين على واقع الحال في الارض ولكن
السؤال المنطقي هل اوروبا مستعده لان لان
تدخل طرفا مباشرا او غير مباشر بالحرب
اعتقد ان الكثير من المحللين السياسيين
يجيبون على السؤال
بلا اوروبا غير مستعده وليست راغبه انظر
الى مستوى
الدعم اللوجستي بموضوع موضوع العتاد هنالك
مشكله كبيره بايرادات العتاد الى الاسلحه
التي وردت الى اوكرانيا يعني حتى الولايات
المتحده اضطرت الى ان تستعين بخزينه
استراتيجي الموجود في كوريا الجنوبيه وفي
اسرائيل لتوريد بعض الذخيره الى اوكرانيا
الا تعتقد ان هناك لعب بالنار من خلال
مساله هذه الامدادات بالسلاح خاصه عندما
نسمع بوتين
في هذه الذكرى ذكرى الانتصار في
ستالينغراد يقول صراحه انها حرب ضد روسيا
بالوكاله ويستخدمون اوكرانيا كذريعه
للهجوم على روسيا الان المواجهه اصبحت
حتميه برايك ام لا
لا طبعا هذا الكلام
نستمع اليه منذ منذ شهور يعني هذه الجسر
لا يتجسم من دعايه الروسيه يعني
تتحدث عن يعني مواجهه مباشره بين حفنيتو
من ناحيه والروسيا من ناحيه اخرى من خلال
اوكرانيا وما الى ذلك نحن نرفض هذا الكلام
تماما والممثل الاعلى سيد بريل قال اكثر
من مره بان
الرغم انه الاتحاد الاوروبي ليس تحالفا
عسكريا وانما مشموع من الدول او تكاتل
اقتصاده وسياسه بامتياز رغم كل ذلك هناك
كسرنا خلينا نقول كثير من الطابوحات خلال
شهور الماضيه بشكل سريع جدا يعني نحن
نتحدث الان
واليول مره في تاريخ الاتحاد الاوروبي ان
يعني
التكاتل اقتصادي وسياسي اللي هو الاتحاد
الاوروبيا اللي يقدم دعم عسكريا بشكل
مباشر لدوله ثالثه ولاول مره مره اخرى في
تاريخ هذا التكاتل نتحدث عن 12 مليار يورو
بالاضافه الى المعدات العسكريه الاخرى من
قبل دول الاضاف الاتحاد الاوروبي طبعا
يعني مقلب كبير جدا بالاضافه طبعا الى
الدبابات الالمانيه يعني كنا نتحدث عن
المانيا قبل قليل كان هناك حديث في
الاتحاد الاوروبي داخل الكواليس خلنا نقول
في الاتحاد الاوروبي حول هذا الموضوع وفي
نهايه المطاف احنا وصلنا لهذه النقطه حيث
قدمت المانيا بالفعل دبابات لي اوكرانيا
كان هناك ايضا اجتماع في هذه المدينه
ماذا قلت صحيح صحيح هناك تداخل من قبل
البيت المتحده في هذه الحاله وافقت
المانيا على ارسال دبابات بان المانيا لا
تريد ان تذهب بهذا الطريق لوحدها ارادت ان
يكون الولايات المتحده ضامنا لامها في حال
تطور الامر ان تدخل المانيا او ان تتعرض
او يتخذ بوتين بعض الحماقات
ويعني ويستهدف المصالح الالمانيه في
العالم
واعتقد انه هذا امر امر طبيعي يعني اذا
نظرنا الى التاريخ المانيا كدوله والثقافه
الالمانيه في هذا المجال مره اخرى هذه اول
مره تقد منذ نهايه الحرب البارده والعقل
نهايه الحرب العالميه الثانيه لنشاهد في
مديح هذه
يعني الخطوات من قبل المانيا من قبل بعد
الدول الاوروبيه سواء كان فنلندا سويديا
دنمارك كان هناك اجتماع في الرمشتاين قبل
عشره ايام تقريبا حول هذا الموضوع مره
اخرى يعني دعم عسكري مباشر لاوكرانيا
اعتقد انه هذه الخطوه او هذه الخطوات
مثيره
للاهتمام وايضا مهمه للغايه اذا مره اخرى
نظرنا الى ما هو الاتحاد الاوروبي لا
نتحدث هنا عن حلف الناتج يعني ان التكاتل
الاقتصادي واجتماعي
اعتقد انه صحيح ان هناك طابوهات ولكن هناك
ايضا وعي لذا الكادروبيين حتى في شاره
الاوروبيه انه نحن في المرحله استثنائيه
تماما هناك دوله اللي شنت حربا او عدوانا
نسكانيه لدوله اخرى في الكروبيه نحن نعتبر
بان اوكرانيا هي دوله اوروبيه بامتياز
فبالتالي نكون ايضا قوي ولكن سايبوريل
ايضا كال بوضوح اكثر من مره بان نحن لا
نعترف انفسنا طرفا مباشرا بهذه الحرب ولكن
علينا ان نساعد ونقدم هذا الدعم مباشر
لاوكرانيا
بتربيه الحلوى سنستمر بذلك طيب عندما تطلب
منكم كاوروبيين يطلب منكم بلد تدريب 1500
جندي وياتي الاتحاد الاوروبي يقول سندرب
الضعف يعني هذا لا تعتبره يعني يمكن ان
يعتبر كرساله قويه
لموسكو انظر الى الاتحاد الاوروبي بصدد
تدريب جنود اوكرانيين طلبه 1500 لا نحن
سندرب 30,000
نعم طبعا يعني هذا مره اخرى اعتقد انه جثه
من هذا الدعم الاوروبيه المباشر للجيش
الاوكراني ولشعب الاوكراني ايضا ونتحدث عن
تدريب في الراديو البولنديه في الرياضيات
الاوروبيه نتحدث عن تدريب فيما يتعلق
باداره بعض الاسلحه غير الفتاكه ويعني
التقديم هذا التدريب
للجنود الاوكرانيين لمواجهه العضوان
الروسي يعني في نهايه المطاف نحن اعتقد
ايضا الرئيس المفضل الاوروبيه كانت واضحه
في التصريحاتها اليوم حول هذا الموضوع
وايضا سالم حول ضروره مواصل لحتى الدعم
لان يعني
بعد الحرب هو مشروط السلام ومن من يهاجم
هذا المشروع من يحدد هذا المشروع روسيا من
خلال هذا العضوان غير مبرر لدوله اخرى
يعني انتهكت روسيا كل المبادئ الاساسيه
بني التحتيه الامنيه في الكروبيه وانتحقت
التزاماتها ايضا في في في يعني خلال
الشهور الماضيه بشكل سارم فنحن طبعا يعني
حتى الامين العاملون المتحده
دخل الى الى الرئيس الروسي
لمحاوله انهاء هذه الحرب الدمويه والرفض
الراي الروسي الرئيس الروسي الرئيس بوتين
ذلك فليس هناك الرغبه اطلاقا لدى السلطات
الروسيه لانهاء هذه الحرب فبالتالي في هذه
الظروف علينا مره اخرى ان نقوم بذلك وايضا
هذا النقطه ايضا مهمه
هي انه نحن نقوم بذلك بموجبه كنا الدولي
هناك ماده في الميثاق الامم المتحده اللي
هي 51
اللي تقول بشكل واضح ايضا انه لاي دوله
الحق للدفاع ان
النفس خلال هذه الظروف يعني امام هذا
رضوان العسكريه المباركه طيب متى تنتظرون
شخصيا من هذه القمه لان الحديث كان مطولا
الاوكرانيين ينتظرون بالفعل ان يعجل
الاتحاد بالقبول باوكرانيا كادو ولكن
عندما نقرا مختلف الصحف نرى بان هذا
الطريق سيكون طويل وانه اوكرانيا لم تلتزم
بعد بالعديد من الاصلاحات المطلوبه وفي
طليعتها مكافحه الفساد
جميل بالمناسبه روسيا هي تطلب مفاوضات
ولكن بوتين هو لا يطمعه السلام روسيا سوف
تستخدم هذه المهله خلال المفاوضات لتعزيز
قواتها لتحقيق تعبئه جزئيه تعبئه العمى
بعض ذلك روسيا صوتها مره ثانيه وهنا نحن
في اوكرانيا نقول بان صيغه ذهبيه
لاوكرانيا هذا الطرد دروس من ارادو
اوكرانيه وانضمام الى النهضه لان السيد
بوتين هو انتقامي جدا بعد هزيمه في
اوكرانيا من الممكن هو سوف يهاجمه على
اوكرانيا مره ثانيه
لهزيمه في اوكرانيا هذا الصفا على وجه
روسيا
تدريجيا تدريجيا قوه مصالحه تطارد الروس
من ارادوكرينيا اوكرانيا حراره تقريبا 60%
من الاراضي
اوكرانيا الان من غرب تقديم اسلحه ثقيله
ومنها معدات عسكريه
هذا لهجوم مضاد ناجحه حول القيمه اللي
بكره يعني بصفه عامه انا اعتقد عمليه
الانضمام اوكرانيا الى اتحاد الاوروبي هي
سوف تكون طويله ثانيا واحد بالمناسبه
اليوم برلمان وروبيا اخذ قرارا او لعمليه
لتجهيز اوكرانيا انضمام الى اوروبا ولكن
ثاني واحد نحن
ضروري تحقيق الواجبات امام الاتحاد ومنها
اصلاحات مختلفه اصلاح خاصه
نحن وجهنا يعني للاسف الشديد وكان هذا
الاقتصادم الاوكراني بان موجود فساد في
ميرزا الان موجود العمليه
التحقيقات حول الكائن كارثه بصراحه لمجتمع
مناسبه مجتمع الاوكراني يطلب من اعدام
لفسدين في ايام الحرب ولكن على كل حال
لاننا لا اعتقد اوكرانيا سوف تدخل في
اتخاذ روبي بفاق يجب اولا اوكرانيا سوف
تنتهي
مع روسيا كمان انضمام الاتحاد الاوروبي
مهم جدا لاوكرانيا لانعاش الصناعه
بشكل منهجي هنا في اوكرانيا طيب عامر
الموسوي الان نقترب تدريجيا من الذكرى
الاولى لبدايه الحرب في اوكرانيا ومع ذلك
لا يوجد اي مؤشر على
بصيص امل في نهايه هذا الحرب عندما نقرا
خاصه تصريحات الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين هذه التساؤلات بدات تطرح على سبيل
المثال في المانيا سؤال الى متى سنستمر في
الحرب والى متى سنظل ننتظر
توفيق الصانع القرار الالماني والاوروبي
بشكل عام يحاول ان يفرض الكثير من
العقوبات والمزيد من العقوبات على القياده
الروسيه وعلى الاقتصاد الروسي هنالك حزمه
يعني عقوبات ستفرض في عشيه السنويه لذكرى
اندلاع الحرب في اوكرانيا وهي الحزمه
العاشره من قبل الاتحاد الاوروبي واعتقد
انها ستفرض عقوبات على اشخاص مقربين من
الرئيس بوتين
واكادوا اجزم بان هذه الخطوه قد تكون
للبعض قد تكون يعني خطوه يعني ليست جوهريه
ولكن العرض بشؤون البيت الروسي والحاكم في
الكريم يدرك بان الضغط على الالغاشيه
الروسيه وعلى رجال الاعمال والمال
المقربون دائما من السلطه في موس يمكن له
ان يؤدي الى ارباك داخل هرم السلطه
بالسلطه المحيطه ببوتين في الكثير من
المحرنين السياسيين هنا في المانيا يعلمون
حق العلم ان اي تغيير مفترضا في راس يعني
القياده الروسيه لا يمكن ان ياتي من
الشارع الروسي او لا يمكن ان ياتي بثوره
او بحركه شعبيه انما ياتي من البيت المحيط
داخل الكرملين
فقدت الصوت
طيب عامر الموسوي يبدو انه في اشكال في
الصوت في اشكال في الصوت معك عوده لضيفي
في عود لضيفي في بيروت انت انت تسمعني
تسمعني ببيروت
ستكون مطابقه للافعال من قبل الاوروبيين
نعم بالصفه دائما بالمناسبه الان ما زال
موجود كهرباء في كيف ولذلك من الممكن هذا
النقاش من جانبي يعني بصفه تعمل نحن نجد
موجوده مساعده كبيره من
غربروس من اراده اوكرانيا بصراحه نحن
شاكرين لصيد الشرطه
من تقديم لاوكرانيا الدبابات ابرم سكانيا
طلبت المتاحه من بدايه حرب تقديم المدرعات
وكمان الدبابات الثقيله ولكن بعيدا هو
الرافضه بالمناسبه حول تدريب
الاوكراني مين تقريبا من سنه 2014 موجود
تدريب الجنود اوكرانيا في معسكرات غربيه
وخاصه في امريكا وكمان في بريطانيا وفي
اوروبا يعني بالصفه بالمناسبه كمان
[موسيقى]
عمليه التدريب باستخدام قتلي مقاتلات
عشره يعني من الممكن في مستقبل اوكرانيا
سوف تحصل على كل هذا المقاتلات بالمناسبه
اوكرانيا تحتاج كل هذا المقاتلات
لدعم هجوم نمو كما في منطقه وكمان في في
الشارقه يعني وكمان في الجنوب ولكن للاسف
الشديد حارته هي سوف تكون طويله ودمويه
للغايه هدف خصائص عند
بعثه جنوب هذا الاحتلال كيف وهذا غير نظام
في اوكرانيا
هو ايارغب ان اوكرانيا لا تدخل في اتحاطه
سوف تبقي في محور التاثير روسيا وبهذا
بصراحه روسيا هاجمت بشكل شامل على بكره
يعني وكما قلت من المنتظر يعني سوف تكون
معارك الدمويه للغايه في منطقه
اعتقد وت
جيدا المساله المطروحه الان على الطاوله
هو هناك في كياب من يطالب بالاسراع في ضم
اوكرانيا الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي مع ان هذا الاجراء يحتاج الى وقت
ووقت طويل وحتى صحيفه لمون تقول هذا لن
يكون غدا
طبعا علينا ان نفهم يعني ما هي عن ماذا
نتحدث نتحدث عن عمليه قانونيه خصوصا يعني
نتحدث عن مفاوضات حول 35 بندا
لاستكمال هذه المفاوضات قبل انضمام اي
دوله مرشح للاتحاد الاوروبي لكن في نفس
الوقت لاول مره في تاريخ الاتحاد الاوروبي
هناك بلد اصبح مرشح رسميا لانضمام الاتحاد
الاوروبي وفي نفس الوقت يعني هذا البلد
يتعرض لي وضوان عسكري من قبل الدوله اخرى
فهناك يعني اعتقد المباشرات مختلفه سواء
كان في اواسم الروبيه وخل يعني اخر
البرلمان الروبي بان نحن نعيش في اوقات
استثنائيه تم احراز تقدما ملموسا من قبل
سلطه الاوكرانيه حول الاصلاحات اللازمه
لبدء هذه المفاوضات
لا لا نستطيع ان ندخل في التكهنات ولكن
مره اخرى اعتقد انه صحيح من ناحيه هذه
العمليه معقده ولكن من ناحيه اخرى نحن
القرار في نهايه المطاف بعيد دول نظافه
مجلس الاتحاد الاوروبي واعتقد ان هناك
ايضا نقاش مهم جدا
يعني بحث عن هذا الموضوع غدا خلال هذه هي
المشورات بين قاده الاوروبيين وايضا
الرئيس الاوكراني اساسي طيب عامر الموسوي
هذه النقطه هي محل توافق الجميع
الكل متفق داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي بان
المعايير معايير الانضمام عليها ان لا
تتغير يعني اوكرانيا مرحب بها بان تدخل
وهنالك رغب اوروبيه وتعاطف شعبي بان تدخل
اوكرانيا الى الاتحاد الاوروبي ولكن ليس
على حساب المعايير التي يجب ان تكون ثابته
هنا ذكر الكثير من المراقبين السياسيين
يقولون بان دولا اضمت الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي وهي يعني لا تستحق الانضمام
يتحدثون عن رو عن بلغاريا بسبب عدم
ايجادي اصلاحات قانونيه وقضائيه في النظام
القضائي والاداري في هاتين الدولتين عموما
حصل من الماضي الى هذا الكلام ولكن اليوم
اوكرانيا ووجود هذه القمه داخل كييف وهي
المره الاولى بالمناسبه ان تعقد هكذا قمه
في دوله في وهي في حاله حرب وهو ما هو
دليل على التعاطف الكبير والرغبه السياسيه
بدعم اوكرانيا ولكن هنالك ايضا بعض
المتخوفين بان عمليه ادخال اوكرانيا بهذا
الشكل السريع وعبور بعض يعني المعايير يجب
ان لا تكون بهذه الشكل
اوكرانيا يجب عليها ان تقوم بالكثير من
الاصلاحات اصلاحات تتعلق باطر قانونيه
معروفه في داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي في
الاداره
والقانون والاقتصاد والصحه والتعليم
المواصلات واعتقد ان اوكرانيا لا تستطيع
ان تصل الى هذا المستوى العالي من
المعايير وهي في حاله الحظ لا ننسى ان
البرلمان الاوكراني يعني بين فتره واخرى
يجيز للرئيس بان يعلن حاله التاهب وهي
قضيه روتينيه ومقبوله ومعروفه ويجب ان
تحصل فكيف من باب ان تدخل في احكام عرفيه
وتوقف اعمال الدستور ومن طرف اخر وطبعا
بسبب الحرب ومن طرف اخر تدخل بعض
الاصلاحات اعتقد ان عمليه الاصلاحات ليس
قرارا سياسيا فقط ان يصدره الرئيس
سيلينسكي ولكنه طريق طويل يحتاج الى
الكثير من الاصلاحات والتعاون والمحادثات
هنالك دول لا تزال تحاول ان تدخل الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي منذ عشر سنوات نتحدث عن
البوسنه ولا نتحدث عن دول في
الجرياتيكي يعني او تاعي حقا بان طريق
الوصول الى العضويه الكامله في الاتحاد
الاوروبي طريق طويل واعتقد ان هذا الطريق
هو ليس بحاله من الاحوال من وجهه نظري
مرتبط بالمقالات التي تؤول بها الحرب يعني
علينا ان نفصل بما يحدث اليوم في ساحات
القتال وبجبهاتها
والنقاشات السياسيه والحوارات السياسيه
التي يعني تجري الان وستجري في المستقبل
حول العضويه الكامله لاوكرانيا طيب يعني
هناك من يسال هل انتم في اوكرانيا على
مسافه واحده مع الولايات المتحده من جهه
مع الاوروبيين من جهه اخرى
وهي بصراحه نحن ما امريكا ونحن ما
اتخاذ الاوروبي في ان واحد بالمناسبه
اوكرانيا حققت كثير من الاصلاحات ومنها
اصلاحات الاداريه وكمان اصلاحات الصحه
ولكن في اصلاحاته لقضاء
واصلاحات القانون وبصراحه انا كمان اعتقد
بان اوكرانيا لن تدخل في اقرب الوقت
لاتحاد اوروبي اهم شيء لاوكرانيا هذا
الانضمام الى الناطور لان كما قلت قبل
روسيا من الممكن سوف تهاجم على اوكرانيا
مره ثانيه بعض الهزيمه هنا في اوكرانيا
ولذلك صيغه الذهبيه لاوكرانيا هذه الاوليه
انضمام الى يعني واحد من ضروري تحقيق
اصلاحات في اقرب الوقت
ولكن
على كل حال للاسف لا ننسى بان اوكرانيا
السبب الذي ساقه بوتين لبدايه الحرب هو
وجود قوات بين قوسين للناتو داخل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه فكيف تريد ان تنضم اوكرانيا
التي الان 30% واقل من مساحه ارضها محتله
من قبل روسيا يعني انه اعتقد من وجهه نظري
انه سكب بالزيت على النار بهذه الحرب نعم
ملاحظه محتله تقريبا 11 من اراد اوكرانيا
ولكن
استخدمت
هجوم على اوكرانيا ولكن غابه تقريبا منذ
سنه ونصف اعلن امين الناتو بان اوكرانيا
لن تدخل في الناتو في عقرب عشره سنوات
ولكن هذا
النظريه روسيا يجب يعني روسيا صوت تهاجمه
الان على فيلم وعلى السويد
ترغب انضمام الى حدود تقريبا
مع روسيا يعني نحن
قضيه هذا الضريع فقط هجوم على اوكرانيا
هذا سبب اساسي هجوم على هذا اوكرانيا
محور تاثير روسيا على اوكرانيا كما نتذكر
وانضمام اوكرانيا الى رغبه انضمام
اوكرانيا الى اتخاذ روبيك ولكن واحد
في سنه 2000 روسيا كمان ارادت انضمام الى
النهضه يعني سخريه القادر الان روسيا
تضاح اوكرانيا
ولكن بصراحه قضيه منطقي لاوكرانيا لان في
سنه
الروسي هجمت على جورجيا واوكرانيا ادركت
اليوم جورجيا بكره اوكرانيا وكان حكمه
اوكرانيا في سنه 2014 روسيا هجمت على
جزء من منطقه يعني على الاقل قضيه الهجوم
الروسي على جورجيا اعتقد انه يحتاج الى
تصحيح جورجيا هي من قامت بالبدر بالعدوان
او بالعمليات العسكريه في اوسيتيا
الجنوبيه وردت عليها روسيا انذاك بهذا
الهجوم الذي يعني تحدثنا عن نحن نعلم بان
روسيا لديها اطماع ولديها مخاوف بان
الناتو يقترب من حدودها وعليها ان تدافعها
كما يقوله الروس ولكن علينا ان ندرك بان
اهم اهم شيء فقده الروس اليوم هو ثقه
الجيران بهذه الدوله ودليل على ما ذكرته
بان فنلندا
التي لطالما لم يشتركها بعضويه الناتو
اليوم بدات المخاوف حتى في الشارع العام
تتصاعد مما دفع هاتين الدولتين بان تقدم
طلبهما الرسميين للانضمام الى الناتو طيب
لويس لويس النقطه هذه النكته
نعم اريد اريد فقط ان اقول بان هذه النقطه
لغايه الاهميه لانه انا اتحدث دائما ان
نتائجك
ما حدث في السويديا وفنلندا يعني الدولتين
اللي يعني منذ سنوات منذ وقود حقيقه كانت
كنت يعني في هذه الموقف الحيادي امام
الروسي وبين الروسيا والاتحاد الاوروبي
والان يعني هي يعني
قررت
يعني اغلبيه كبيره جدا داخل البرلمان
الدنماركي للانضمام الى ما يسمى سياسه
الامنيه الاوروبيه لاول مره في تاريخ هذا
البلد وبالاضافه طبعا اكيد ان هناك اغلبيه
من الاوكرانيين اليوم الذين
يريدون الانضمام الى النيتو ولكن ربما هذا
الامر لم يكن كذلك قبل هذه الحرب فهناك
طبعا مخافه لكن لا نستطيع يا سيد اذكارن
21 ان نعيش في مثل هذه المراحل او هذه
يعني المراحل التاريخيه هل نقول حيث نرى
بان هناك دوله يعني تعتبر بان بانها لها
او لها الحق للقيام دوله اخرى لانه هي تقع
فيما يسمى بمناطق النفوذ يعني مناطق
النفوذ هذا
المفهوم يعني
كنا نستمع اليه يعني قبل قرنين تقريبا كنا
نكره في هذا الموضوع لكن اليوم اليوم
نتحدث عن ضروره التعاون الدولي حول معوديه
مثل داخل الوباء وما الى ذلك وهناك دوله
تعيش في في الكارن
يعني
سابقه تماما
غير مقبول الله الدولية
يعني فقط انها دوله نوويه ومع الاسف يعني
صحيح مع الاسف عين الاعتقالات الطريقه
التي
قويه مع الاسف طيب لويسمي قالها نفهم من
هذا الكلام
انا الجغرافيا السياسيه
عسكرت او تمت عسكرتها الى درجه اننا
ابتعدنا كليا عن خيار
امكانيه التفاوض
هلا يعني اعتقد انه هناك امر واضح
الجغرافيه لن تتغير يعني روسيا ستكون
جار لاوكرانيا وجار الاتحاد الاوروبي الى
الابد
يعني خلينا نتحدث بوضوح الجغرافيه هي زي
ما هي لكن اعتقد انه وصلنا لنقطه تحاول
تاريخيا وسياسيا لا يمكن يعني مثلا خذ
الموضوع الطاقه كان هناك اعتماد كبيره
للروسيا من قبل الاتحاد الاوروبي تقع
الروسيه وهذه كانت يعني
استراتيجي نحن اتفقنا لذلك لكن ناخذ مثلا
المانيا ما حدث في المانيا خلال شهور
الخليه الماضيه لما حدث هي يعني هو
التحولات سياسيه عميقه جدا يعني اليوم
المانيا لا تعتمد نهائيا لا تقع روسيا
وبالاضافه الى ذلك اوروبا ايضا على الطريق
او في التاريخ للتخلص بشكل كامل من هذا
الاعتماد على التقريصيه وفقد الروسيه من
خلال هذه الشهور الماضيه الكثير لانه
نتحدث عن سوق موحده اكبر سوق موحده بلا حد
الاوروبي يعني نتحدث عن فقدان اكثر من
مليارين
مليونين عفوا فصل خمسه برميل يوميا من
النفته الروسي باتجاه الاتحاد الاوروبي
يعني كيف يمكن للروسيا النقل كل هذه
الكميه من النفث او من الغاز لمناطق اخرى
هو كان اسيا اخرى بدعافه الى انه روسيا
الان تبيع هذه
الامدادات الطاقه بالديسكام بالخصم الكبير
يعني تقريبا خمسين بالمئه
يعني اعلنت شركه هذه الايام انه صادراتها
النفسيه تراجعت بشكل كبير يعني يتحدث هنا
عن 46% من التراجع الصادراتها للخارج
فهناك اعتقد بسبب العقوبات الاوروبيه
والامريكيه وما الى ذلك تضعيات واضحه
للاقتصاد الروسي لماذا لانه روسيا هي التي
كررت بنهايه المطاف يعني بالقيام بهذا
العضوان غير المبرر اوكرانيا فتضايات
واضحه ولكن ايضا هناك تحولات سياسيه واضحه
جدا في القاره الاوروبيه
توفيق ان سمحت لي في هذه النقطه اريد ان
اضيف الى ما قاله السيد ميغيل في المانيا
هنالك ثوره انصحها التعبير ثوره في الطاقه
عندما يتغير الصناعه الالمانيه من الطاقه
الاحفوريه الى طاقه النظيفه
عفوا بهذا الوقت البسيط السريع يعني انه
تحول صناعي كبير
التحول الاخر بعد الحرب في اوكرانيا اصبح
من المقبول لدى الراي العام في المانيا ان
تتسلح المانيا باسلحه اكثر تطورا وان تنفق
الدوله الالمانيه المزيد الاموال على
التسليح قبل هذا الموعد لم تكن هنالك اي
رغبه شعبيه بان تنفق الحكومه الالمانيه
اموالا على التسليح بسبب البعد التاريخي
ولكن عندما ما حصل في اوكرانيا ويحصل
اليوم دفع هؤلاء المترددين المتخوفين من
الصراعات العسكريه الى قطع ترددهم
وقبول اي حكومه المانيه تنفق المزيد من من
الاموال على الاسلحه هنالك نقطه ثالثه
الجيران المانيا قبل حرب اوكرانيا كانوا
يتخوفون ان انفقت المانيا على ترسانه
عسكريه وايضا بسبب المخاوف التاريخيه
لالمانيا لا ننسى ان المانيا لديها حدود
طويله وكبيره مع دول المجاوره لها
والاقتصاد الالماني لديه القدره على
الانفاق العسكري والتكنولوجي ولكن هذه
المخاوف سقطت ليله وضحاها واصبح
البولنديين على سبيل المثال يقبلون بان
المانيا تنفق 100 مليار يورو في هذا العام
على الانفاق العسكري مضافا الها خمسون
مليار يورو الانفاق السنوي العسكري
لالمانيا القضيه فيها هذا الموضوع
سنشهد في السنوات الخمس الماضيه الخمس
القادم لان المقبله بان المانيا ستبني
جيشا كبيرا
مزودا باحدث الاسلحه ويكون لديه قدره
ضاربه للدفاع وهذه القضيه هي تحول
دراماتيكيا في قرننا هذا طيب ولدي امير
قمتم بثوره برتقاليه واذا بكم انتم تغيرون
المشهد كليا في في دهل الجوار
نعم بصراحه لماذا كانت كل هذه الثورات في
اوكرانيا لان بصراحه اوكرانيا ارادت خروج
من المنطقه النفوظ من روسيا وانضمام الى
اتحاد اوروبي وبهذا كانت الثورات في
2014 موافي 2004 يعني بصفه عمل للاسف
الشديده طريق اوكرانيا هو طويل الى
طويل الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي ولكن نحن
في نهايه المطاف سوف تدخل الى
الناطور
وكمان ضروري تحقيق الاصلاحات هنا في
اوكرانيا
بصفه عامه يجب ان ننتهي قبل كل شيء هذا
حرب مع روسيا وطرد روسي من اراد اوكرانيا
الشكر في الختام من بيروت لويس ميجال
الرسمي للاتحاد الاوروبي بمنطقه الاوسط
وشمال افريقيا الشكر من كيابير شوماكوف
وهو دبلوماسي اوكرانيا سابق وشكرا برلين
لعمل المساوا وزميل صحفي ومحلل سياسي شكرا
لفريق البرنامج امسيه مريحه للجميع
[موسيقى]